can't see
the power
that's coming out of my body when I do
this
Nick can feel well what whatever's that
so I'm changing the words to Adrenaline
so if you do this you get what I call an
adrenaline pump
cool that feels Oh I thought whoa I'm
getting bigger I feel more like a
monster you know so you
so to me it's Coke you
but if you're going to just go half
hardly you're not going to stimulate
your
your adrenaline
so I've seen lots of different things
please
so
[Applause]
Sheeran Aggie was the hand thumb up the
wrist must be flat
down a lot of you are bringing this arm
up to about here and there you're
finding it difficult to get under them
wherever
like with the Scentsy John's Point
wherever this is that's the level that
you
go at
you don't want to disturb that so you've
your some of you are understanding this
this wants to be as up light as possible
and again someone said to me God that's
quite powerful on your own wrist isn't
it doing that and it is yes
you know some people do press-ups like
that
so you do have to really work at that so
this one was sheer Naggy
and you're going to be really
so simplified what is if the thumb goes
down
so now we've got two techniques
just by one
feeling
all right so we've got two techniques so
like I said today is all about hands
Shia Nagi
cut a gosh
it doesn't matter to me
um
but you need to pump up your adrenaline
so I'm trying to get you all to actually
feel bigger than you are
you go through stages some of you'll go
through what I call an ego stage when
you pump up your adrenaline cool yeah
I'm starting I can throw them now so but
that's right since the user say if all
you have is strength use it until it
turns to Coke you
your partner might not like that
attitude but
sheeranagi
hello guys
all right so we're making now simplified
Aikido aren't we simplified chernagi
Coda gosh
the only difference between the Sheeran
Aggie footwork
one and the guys footwork is so
it's very really quite simple isn't it
shinagi
color guys what's Halfway sheer Nagi you
see
and before you land
the foot floats here
so not too much information but I'd like
you to do the coder guys if you want to
slip in this Sheeran Aggies just to get
your mind focused on where they're
fitting
but what I don't want to see is your
hands going limp because you're starting
to think
all right it's all today is all about
this
John John said to me says he just said
to me cool you've got to really work on
that wrist I said do my Roti Dory like
he was and he went oh yeah
so when we do maruti Dory we we really
work on all this don't we
and then we put it down and forget about
it again well so today I'm saying you're
working on your muroti Dory she and
Aggie you're working on your motor door
with your coat of gosh
it's still here just because it's in a
different place it doesn't mean to say
that it hasn't got the same Dynamics
okay